[THEME MUSIC]
ROBERTO BARBERO: We
want to show you--
I'm very, very excited
to be here and show you
how we can make together
Salesforce and Google Cloud
a customer engagement platform.
First of all, just
to move a little bit,
can I ask you to yes raise
your hands who of you are
in the business area?
Who of you make the business
decisions in your companies?
OK.
Cool.
Who of you are
developers, the guys
that actually really
make the decisions?
[LAUGHS]
Cool.
Who of you-- do you use
Salesforce in your company?
That's a very good--
and who you is right now
doing or planning on doing
some kind of IoT project?
Amazing.
This is your session, actually.
This is your session.
You're in the right place.
We are-- what I want you
guys to understand here today
are three main things.
One is that we are going to help
you bring value from the data
you're getting from IoT,
which is very, very important.
The second one is that we are
bringing together our IoT--
blending our IoT
knowledge on Google Cloud
on how to secure the
communication, how to scale,
how to get insights from
that data with the 360
view of the customer that
service can give you.
And the last one is that
we are here for you.
We have done it before,
and we can help you do it.
This is real.
So now this wouldn't
be a real IoT session
if I would not start
with a huge number.
It has to be like that.
8.4 billion of
devices, Gartner says,
were connected to the internet--
IoT devices were-- in 2017.
It's important, the
growth that we had,
the 36% growth between 2016
and 2017 is incredible.
And this number of
devices that are going up
is just getting faster
and faster, as you know.
20 billion by 2020, Gartner
says that we're going to have.
Now, these devices, what they're
doing is generating data.
And we are generating data
faster and faster and faster.
Just a single
engine from a plane
has more than 5,000 sensors.
It's generating 10 gigabytes
of data per second.
If we add all of that
for a whole day--
and I won't-- I don't know you,
but I won't go on a plane that
has only one engine--
that is more information on a
single plane flying 12 hours
than the amount of data that
we got on social media in 2016.
The machines are generating
an amazing amount of data.
So what?
That's the main thing.
When a customer
calls me in and say,
I want to connect my devices,
IoT is pretty cool, I say why?
And this is the main question.
This is, how do
I use IoT to make
it useful for the business?
How could I get
value from that data?
This what all of
us should be here.
And this is the important thing.
Every single time I visit one of
my customers, I tell them why.
And if they can answer and they
have a good value for that,
then I go ahead.
I just realized that I
haven't introduced myself.
My name is Roberto Barbero.
As you have heard, I'm Spanish.
So I just realizing that if
you took a Spaniard to give
a speech in less
than 15 minutes,
you get someone that
speaks very, very fast.
So stop me there,
raise your hand.
My job in Google, I am IoT
specialist covering Europe,
Middle East, and Africa.
And my job is not to
sell IoT, which is great.
It's to make you--
make my customers get the
best solution [INAUDIBLE] IoT.
So this is what I do.
This is what I do.
I try to make my customers
understand that it's not
about connecting devices.
Connecting devices in
IoT, the announcement
that we heard from
England this morning,
is just a way to get
information in the cloud.
What I do with that is
what really matters.
So I have the data.
I start doing things,
and many of my customers
tell me, well, we have heard
about IoT for a few years now
and we are already there.
We have invested in connecting
my products, connecting my car,
connecting my machines on
my manufacturing plant.
I am connecting my lights.
And in the end, what we
have-- or what they have--
is silo-- solutions
that are siloed on IoT.
But IoT is evolving.
My customers, the ones that
are more advanced or hopefully
if you start working with us
today, I'm going to tell you,
you have to have a different
idea, a different strategy
in IoT.
You need to find an
end to a solution,
thinking what I want to do,
and starting from the device
until the end, go in
a single platform.
That is going to give you
the tools and the solutions
to get the value and the
intelligence from that data.
So very quickly I'm going to
show you what we usually do.
And it's very important
because there are two,
three points here that you will
see what I'm talking about.
First we have to start
with the business case.
We have to start with what--
why do I need that data.
Then we have the
devices that we need
to connect in a
secure way, then we
have the Cloud solution
where it's going
to give you the scalability.
It's going to give
you the security.
It's going to give you the
tools to make that happen.
Then your company
probably is going
to build an application
on top of that,
and you're going to connect that
to CRM, probably Salesforce,
ERP, and other solutions.
Then comes what is
important for you,
which is what information is
going to get that is going
to transform your business.
And finally, you're
going to have
a product that was static
and now is a 24/7 product.
It's a product that
is alive, and you
have to be support
to your customers.
We have begun here with
the business case probably
to do something
with our customers.
We are going in the middle
with the business system
connecting to CRM, which
is about your customers,
and we end giving support
to your customers.
You see the trend here.
IoT and your customer,
and as Marc Benioff,
the CEO of Salesforce
says, "behind every device
there is a customer," is
what you should have in mind
when you look for one
of these solutions.
So how do we do it at Google?
We have three legs here.
We have the technology, and
this what Next is all about.
Do you have heard?
What is and is not
only about IoT Core.
It's about all the
different solutions
that we have around it.
Then we have the
expertise to do that.
We have an amazing
team of people
that can help you do that.
And then last but not least,
we have our amazing partners.
And I am excited to having
here with Salesforce
today because this is one
of the best publishers
that we have on IoT.
I touched something over here.
This is just to show you
that this is life exactly.
There we go.
Now, finally if we see from
the first leg, the technology,
IoT Core is the starting point.
It's just the gateway.
It's just the way
that we bring data
in a secure way
and a scalable way
and managing the
devices into the cloud.
But then you have all of
the rest of the solutions,
as we will see later in
the demo, that can make
that happen and make that--
give you that value
that we are looking for.
And then the third leg,
we have our partners.
And to see what Salesforce
can bring us to this solution,
I'm very pleased
to introduce you
to Lisa D'Alessandro,
senior director, IoT
and platform strategy
partnerships from Salesforce.
Give her applause.
[APPLAUSE]
LISA D'ALESSANDRO: Thank you.
So this is the way.
Yes.
There we go.
So what can you do
with Salesforce IoT?
So I'd like to tell you,
ladies and gentlemen, we
are on the brink of a
technological revolution that
will fundamentally alter the
way that we live and work
and interact with one another.
So the Fourth
Industrial Revolution,
this is the revolution
I'm talking about.
But let's think back to
previous industrial revolutions.
For example, in the
1700s, there was steam.
In the 1800s, there
was electricity.
In the 1900s, there
was computing--
what you're all doing now,
looking at your phones
instead of listening to me.
That's OK.
But now we're on the brink
of this Fourth Industrial
Revolution, and
what does that mean?
What does that-- what kind
of technologies does that
introduce?
So let's think about
how previously it
was very linear in terms
of how we move forward.
But now it's exponential.
And so with AI, with machine
learning, with robotics,
with 3D printing,
these are all things
that are really contributing
to the Fourth Industrial
Revolution.
And you need to think
about how are you
going to adopt these
technologies in order
to move forward to move
your business forward.
And one of these
technologies is IoT.
So let's talk a
little bit about IoT.
So as Roberto mentioned,
your customers
are more connected than ever.
Behind every customer,
there is a device.
Behind every device,
there is a customer.
And so these are devices
that are always on.
They're very smart.
They are powered by AI.
And they transact in real time.
And you need to be able
to transact in real time
as well with your customers.
And there's a gap.
So there's a gap right now
between what customers expect
and how we do customer
service nowadays.
And what you guys
need to figure out
is how do you bridge that gap.
And one of the ways that
you can bridge that gap
is with IoT because
80% of B2B customers
expect that you transact
with them in real time.
So are you doing that right now?
Have you thought
about how are you
going to harness the power
of the Fourth Industrial
Revolution?
How are you going to
harness AI and IoT to drive
your business forward?
So Salesforce IoT
can help you unlock
the potential of your
connected products,
so you can get IoT data from
your devices to help you
and your customers exceed
their expectations.
So we've got connected
things, and we hook that up
to the Google
Cloud IoT platform.
They take that data, they
do some transformation,
they may do some
other things with it
in terms of the other products
and services that they have,
and they send that
to Salesforce IoT.
What does Salesforce
IoT do with it?
Takes that device data
and it enriches it
with all the rich contextual
data that you already
have in Salesforce,
because many of you
said you're
Salesforce customers.
So you can leverage your current
investment in Salesforce,
add on IoT, and, voila, you can
trigger some sort of an action,
a customer engagement
in Salesforce.
So what might that look like?
So, for example, let's talk
about my smartwatch here.
So when I look at
my smartwatch, I
know how many miles
I've gone today,
how many miles I want to go,
how many more I have to go,
and whether or not I'm
winning the competition
with my neighbor
in terms of doing
more miles than he or she.
But I can tell you right now,
if my watch isn't giving me
the information that I
need, what am I going to do?
I'm going to go to
one of my competitors.
I'm going to get their watch.
And that's what you
need to think about.
If you're not adopting an
IoT strategy that works,
your competitors are going
to take your business.
So what can Salesforce IoT do?
We can build amazing
customer experiences.
So, for example,
low-code/no-code declarative
platform, which basically
means that you can enact an IoT
strategy in a matter of
days, a matter of weeks,
not months or years.
This is immediate.
As a business user,
you can do this.
Another thing is that
we've integrated our IoT
with the rest of
our CRM platform,
so you can rich
your IoT with all
of the data from Service
Cloud and Sales Cloud
and any of the other information
that you have in CRM.
And finally, proactive
customer engagement.
I mean, that's what we're
really talking about.
We don't want to be
reactive nowadays
we don't want to think, oh, I
wonder what my customer needs.
We want to proactively
engage with them
through this IoT platform.
So let's talk a little
bit about how we work
and how we complement the
Google Cloud Platform.
So basically as we said
before, we get the device
from these things--
the data from these things.
And we put it into the
Google Cloud Platform.
And then we sent it
the Salesforce IoT.
And what we do there
is we create a profile.
And that profile is IoT data
as well as contextual data
that we get from Salesforce.
And then we create what we
call an orchestration, which
is basically a bunch
of business rules
that we apply to
these profiles, and we
trigger again some sort of
proactive customer engagement.
That could be in Sales
Cloud, or Service Cloud,
or Marketing Cloud.
And one of the other things
that you need to consider
is what other data
might you need.
What other data might
want to pull in?
So you might want to
pull in third-party data,
for example, weather data.
You might want to pull
in Google Maps data.
And just to give a quick
example of how this might work,
let's say it's a very warm day.
And you have a Coca-Cola
cooler in your office,
and you want to
get to your office
and get a nice cold Coke out.
But you know since
it's really warm out,
there's probably not going
to be a lot of Coke left
in there when you get there.
Well, Coca-Cola
also knows that it's
a warm day out because
they have an IoT platform
and they're saying,
oh, OK, you know what?
We've got our third-party
data from the Weather Service.
We know it's going to
be really warm out,
and we can look
inside a Salesforce
and we can see where
our coolers are.
And we can see that we
have a field service
guy who can actually go out
and actually dispatch some more
Coke to-- proactively--
to that location
so that when you
get to the office
you can have your
nice cold Coke.
That's an example
of how IoT can work.
So hopefully if you
have any other questions
around Salesforce IoT,
you'll stick around.
You can ask us afterwards.
I'd now like to introduce my
colleague Aubrey Wing, who's
actually going to talk about
and provide a demo on how
this is really going to work
as well with the refrigerator.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUBREY WING: Hi, everybody.
If we could go ahead and
switch over to the demo screen.
Of course, since it's a
demo, computer went to sleep,
so Roberto, I'm going to have
to ask you to log back in.
While we're doing that,
what I wanted to do was just
give you a high-level
overview of the use case
that we're going
to see in the demo.
And we're going to see
the demo in two parts.
The first half is
going to be Google.
The second half is
going to be Salesforce
and really watching the
two pieces work together.
But the key thing that you're
hearing in this session today
is that you want to think
about your use case.
You want to go ahead and
make sure that you're
driving business value.
So ultimately what we're
going to take a look at
is how you can apply IoT
to answer some really
exciting business questions.
And so what I wanted
to do was start
by introducing our use
case, and then we'll
go into the different
pieces here.
It is a demo, you guys.
You can see that
this is in fact live.
So our use case here is
based upon logistics.
It's a pharmaceutical use case
where really the underlying
driver is to go ahead and
ensure product quality.
And product quality comes
across three primary dimensions.
First and foremost,
I want to make
sure I have the right
level stock in the places
that it's needed the most.
So think of this as do
I have the right stock
level in New York or
London or San Francisco.
The second aspect of
this are the assets
that I own to make sure that
the product is within spec.
So think of this as all of
the refrigerated box cars
or all of the
airplanes that we use
to make sure that we're moving
product from place to place.
And the third is, especially in
high-value products or anything
that has a determined
spec, that we
want to go ahead
and say that we're
keeping that as it should be.
So in this case, we're
monitoring environmentals--
the right temperature, the right
humidity, the right pressure,
whatever it may be.
So put it simply, is my
product the right place,
is it the right
quality, am I keeping
track of cold chain custody?
Bunch of different use cases
all driving towards a singular
business experience.
Now historically
what has happened
is that's three
separate logic sets.
You'll have to join
them and then test them.
So that's months and
months and months.
And with Google
and Salesforce, we
can go ahead and get
something like that working
and the matter of
weeks not months.
And, in fact the
business analysts
can go ahead and build that.
So just to highlight real
quick, what we're looking at
is Salesforce IoT here.
But then we're going to
work backwards and see
how these two work together.
So I mentioned
earlier, if you look
in the upper
left-hand corner, you
see a warning around
geolocation or geoboundary.
The second we're
going to see here
is our evaluation
of the equipment.
Is in fact the equipment--
is the door jammed?
Is it operating?
Is it pulling high voltage?
And the last is
actually temperature.
And to represent this, this
wouldn't be an IoT demo
if we didn't in fact
have hardware here
so you can see this run live.
We have a refrigerator
representing the cold chain.
We have a sensor
pack in here that's
going to give us live readings.
And so to best
highlight that, I'm
actually going to
turn the stage back
to Roberto, who will take
you through the Google site.
ROBERTO BARBERO: Thank you.
Can we just go back for
a second to these lights?
Because I would like to show
you what is the architecture
that we are seeing here.
So we have-- in fact, being
an IoT demos, what we said,
out of reach inside there is--
let me show you.
We have our sensors running
here, happily, as you can see.
It's blinking.
It's live.
I have temperature,
humidity, pressure.
I have many, many, many sensors
embedded here on this fridge.
So, yes, make sure that the
chain is working correctly.
This Raspberry-- these sensors
are sitting actually using
the Wi-Fi--
fingers crossed-- the
data to the cloud.
Of course, we have at
the very front IoT Core.
IoT Core is giving
me the security.
It's giving me this--
the device management,
it's giving me
this capability to bring
these things to the cloud.
IoT Core is glued to Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is our queuing system.
It's kind of like the way that
I can get information and make
sure that this
telemetry data is not
lost if I have silently a
burst of information coming in.
And then Pub/Sub is also
the same time the way
that I can plug in the different
pieces of the solution that
will give you a
Google Cloud platform.
If I go southbound, for
example, we have Dataflow.
Probably I will have
different sensors
from the truck that is
transporting these vaccines.
And I have information about
what it is from the GPS,
and I have information from
the temperature and so on.
I have to make sure that
all that information is
put together in real time.
And this is what Dataflow
is going to help you to do.
In real time, you can
transform the data.
You can massage the data to
make sure it's in the format
and complement that data to make
sure that you have everything
that you need.
And then I'm going to
store the data somewhere.
Here in this example we
are using BigQuery, our--
you heard a lot about BigQuery
right now, our data warehouse
solution, but depending
on your use case,
we can suggest which is the
best storage solution for you.
From there, what I am doing
is just gathering this data
so I can show you in real
time how it is showing.
If I go northbound, I
have Cloud functions,
which is just a small piece
of code that is actually--
it's actually
triggered by something,
in this case, the telemetry
that comes from the sensors.
And that is going
to make the solution
and inject that data
into Salesforce.
And Aubrey will show you
a bit more about that.
So let me just go
back to the demo, now
that you have seen
the main architecture,
just to make sure that you
see that this is actually
in real time.
This is the old information
that is coming in.
And for those of
you that would like
to see a bit more under the
hood what this is about,
this is the Google
Cloud Platform console.
And I have here, we say it--
IoT Core is the first step.
IoT Core, I have
different registries here.
I have the registry, which is
just how I group the devices.
And as you will see, this
registry has some devices.
In this case, I have
three fridges here.
I have the one that is
in San Francisco that
is communicating.
And I can see all the
telemetry data when it happens.
If I dig down a little bit,
I can show you, for example,
how I connect IoT Core.
I said-- I talked about
security-- a device should not
have-- is not a person.
It shouldn't have a user
name and a password.
For us, a device will have
its own private key that
is only known by the device.
I will use that private key to
sign tokens to talk with us.
IoT caller will then
take the path publicly,
just matches the token
that the service has--
their device has sent to us.
So I'm sure that the device
is exactly who it says it is.
And from now on,
that information,
the telemetry data, is coming
encrypted into IoT Core.
The next step from
IoT Core is Pub/Sub.
That is just a bit boring.
I can show you here that
this registry is sending me
telemetry data to
this Pub/Sub topic--
this queuing system.
And if you remember, the
next step is Dataflow.
What I am doing this real-time
transformation of the data.
I have one here that is doing
something very, very simple
for the demo purposes of this.
It's just reading the telemetry
data that comes from Pub/Sub.
The Raspberry is
actually sending the data
in JSON format.
And I want the data to
be injected in BigQuery,
so I am transforming
that into BigQuery format
and then injecting
it into BigQuery.
And the last step
is store the data.
So here I have my Datastore
in BigQuery with all the data
from the fridge.
And I'm going to actually
just query the table so you
see that this is coming live.
So I want to see everything
from this data set,
and I'm going to order
it by the timestamp.
For those of you that use
Salesforce and [INAUDIBLE],,
you know where this
is coming from.
Descending, I run the query, and
you will see that at 20:59 UTC,
I am receiving telemetry
data that actually 20.62--
22.63 corresponds to the live
data I'm getting for there.
So this data-- you remember
this is a southbound.
I am getting these data, and I
am going to analyze that data.
I can do something
meaningful with it.
The last piece-- if you
remember, if I go northbound--
I have a Cloud
function that has been
triggered every single time.
So every three
seconds when this--
the Raspberry is sending me
data every three seconds,
I have this function
that is kicking in,
and I can show you
that what it's doing
is actually connecting
to Salesforce.
Everything is finishing
with a status OK.
So, Aubrey, if you want to show
us what happens after this.
AUBREY WING: Absolutely.
Great.
Thank you, Roberto.
I think that the best thing to
think about from the next step
is that as the northbound
lanes start sending data,
this is our
bi-directional ability
to communicate back
and forth with GCP.
You're seeing the
information here
directly from our fridge
and a Raspberry Pi.
I gave you a quick
view just a minute ago
on what it looks like
in terms of Salesforce.
Again, in Salesforce,
our mission
is to make IoT
really accessible.
We're taking, in this
case, a state machine,
which can be a very powerful
and sophisticated thing that we
can offer to big business
users to make it accessible
and solve real-world
business problems.
So I mentioned earlier,
the different states
as we go through from
normal to warning
across the different use
cases all the way to fault.
What happens at that point is
that we're able to take action.
So you think about Google
as anomaly detection,
a lot of data, the ability to
go ahead and manage security,
to go ahead and manage
data moving back and forth,
provide data services.
With Salesforce,
we'll allow you to do
is take the anomaly detection
and turn that into response.
The response is
the last mile where
we have that customer
behind the scenes.
So what I'm going to
do here is I'm actually
going to reach over and
change one of the parameters.
You'll see it change on
both the Google as well
as the Salesforce site.
So if we go ahead
and take a look
at the hardware real quick.
For the folks in the front
row here, but certainly
we can go ahead and
show you later on,
I'm going to increase one
of the environmentals--
the temperature and humidity.
I'm going to be very fancy
here just to do this manually.
Hold on a second.
We'll keep working on this.
And what you're going to see,
as soon as it gets the reading,
is that we're going to go
ahead and change states.
There it is.
So we now have a
temperature warning.
Keep going.
ROBERTO BARBERO: Keep
blowing, keep blowing!
AUBREY WING: I feel like
I'm blowing up balloon
animals at a birthday party.
I think that'll do it.
And the reason why we do
this, we introduce states,
is that with IoT, you're
going to continue-- get
a continuous flow of data where
you do not want to necessarily
respond to the first event.
There we go.
All right.
We have our case.
We don't necessarily want to
respond to the first event.
So let's say, for
example, my business logic
was around stimulus response,
which is a really common way
to look at this.
I get a reading.
I open a case.
I actually send-- let's
say a field dispatch,
but I'm getting a reading at
the rate of once per second.
So I'm going to get 60 cases or
60 dispatch notices in a minute
if I'm not more
sophisticated with this.
So what we're doing here,
as Lisa mentioned earlier,
is that we're contextualizing.
You have our fridge data coming
in off the left-hand side.
It's an example of the streaming
live event data that we're
getting from GCP.
We're adding the asset data,
really important elements.
When was this in service?
Does it have a warranty?
What should we be doing?
So what I'm going
to show you here
is all of the logic that sits
behind the scenes of the states
that you just saw.
Now a little bit of
an eye chart-- again,
happy to go over this
with you in more detail
either after the
session or I'm going
to encourage you to go to either
the GCP IoT or the Salesforce
booths downstairs.
Love to dig into this stuff.
But bottom line is, you can,
without having to program,
get access to very
sophisticated functionality.
We can go back and say,
what are our targets?
How long do you want to wait?
One of the keys here is
that when I had a fault,
I'm going to check
for a warranty.
And the reason why I
do that is because I'm
going to behave
different depending
on the contextual information
contained within Salesforce.
The customer has a warranty,
I open a case, I dispatch.
They are automatically
entitled to service rights
if they don't have a warranty.
We open an opportunity
to sell them a warranty
or perhaps sell them
the replacement parts.
If they're in a
marketing campaign,
perhaps we're going to
alter the marketing.
One event will change
the entire relationship
a customer can
have with the brand
across multiple functions.
So I do want to highlight
that as one of the key things
that we bring to the table.
What does a case look like?
In this case, this is the asset.
Salesforce IoT requested
a response independent.
You can start automating
these key business processes
and determining what your ideal
customer experience should be.
And ultimately, we're able to
see IoT information directly
inside CRM or Salesforce.
Now if you go and you look
at the entire architecture
while you're all here--
why are we here?
The physical things in
IoT have a digital voice.
That digital voice is what your
customers want to tell you.
Use the data to listen to
the customers, use sales--
use GCP to process
and gain insight to be
able to manage the
identity, use Salesforce
to be able to connect to
your customer directly.
That being said, I believe
we've resolved our problem.
There it is.
So we're back to normal.
I think because I threw
it back in the fridge,
but if you guys want to
manually change this,
you're absolutely welcome to.
And again, as we think about the
possibilities of the use case,
this is where I
get very excited.
The key takeaway here is that
IoT architecture improving
end to end is something
that's well-traveled.
We know the different pieces.
We know the hardware.
We know the services--
the cloud services.
We know what different elements
can be brought together
and the creativity
of the use case
is really where
things come together.
And actually what I
do want to mention
is one of the highlights
that Roberto started off
our discussion with is around
the power of the ecosystem.
Obviously you're seeing GCP
and Salesforce together here.
But I do want to highlight
the services component.
We did a lot of our
use case prototyping,
and in fact, a lot of the work
that was done here on the demo
was with a partner--
service partner of ours.
Dave Stanton of Appirio
is the front row,
and I do want to
give you a shout-out
and thank you for all the
input, especially things
like the warranty.
How do you manage
that separately?
What would you do different
in terms of the logic?
This is where having
the experience of what
the customers are
really looking for
helps bring real business value.
The other thing I do
want to highlight,
if we go back to the slides.
Salesforce and Google,
Google and Salesforce,
we have a joint customer
that is using proactive--
using our IoT to provide
proactive service.
ROUSH CleanTech is a great
example of the business value
you can bring to the table.
What ROUSH CleanTech
is doing is they're
monitoring fleet for service,
proactively making sure
that service vehicles,
school buses, are on the road
and that they are
working assets.
So if you think about the
customer experience that
sits behind the
business case, I want
to make sure that a school
bus or a fleet vehicle
is on the road and working.
And the way we're
going to do this, VIN.
We're going to get a
check engine light.
We're going to get
engine telemetry.
But more than that,
we're going to be
able to analyze this
for proactive service.
How do we take that vehicle
and bring it in for service
before there's
actually a problem?
Quick example here of
what they're doing,
and if you start you can see how
architecturally we've brought
a lot of these different
pieces together
and continue to add great use
cases, geofence monitoring.
How do I go ahead and get this
to the nearest service depot,
not just a service depot?
How do I have
proactive diagnostics
around fuel systems
and predictive service,
again keeping these
things working.
So with that, what
I'd like to do
is introduce Colin Mara,
who will bring us home.
[APPLAUSE]
COLIN MARA: Thanks, Aubrey.
Thanks, Aubrey.
I'm here to wrap
things up or help--
if there's one
thing you can leave
with today from
the session would
be that the togetherness
between Google and Salesforce
will really
complement each other.
We talked about how from
the physical end device,
connecting that to Google Cloud
IoT Core, getting that data,
being able to manage those
devices securely, push out
updates, manage the users that
are involved, and then get it
into the traditional
Google product sets--
GCP product sets-- for
machine learning, BigQuery,
all those types of things.
And then where you really
need to have the action take
place in your business systems
and CRM, the leading player out
there is Salesforce.
Get that data into Salesforce
where actions can really
take place and you can really
enhance your experience,
your customers'
experience together.
So the idea here is we've got
best-of-breed products here
between Google--
World Class Google,
Salesforce together
will help you streamline
this process, your journey--
your IoT journey, make it
easier for you to really see
the value, and get the
benefits from that.
Slide?
Oh, do I have to do it here?
I'm sorry.
I thought he was
doing the slide.
So before we wrap up
here, one of the things
I want you all to
know about what
you can do after this-- you've
seen a little bit of the demo.
You can attend-- there's a
few more IoT breakout sessions
that are going on at the show.
Check out the IoT
showcase on the show floor
at Moscone South.
There's an IoT solution
sections that Google has.
They're showing some
other virtual demos
that are going on.
You can get a free ice
cream over at the maps.
Or we're pulling in a number of
the different Google products
and capabilities
within IoT, and you'll
be able to see that on display,
ask questions, et cetera.
There's also the
Salesforce booth, which
will have a version of this.
And you can kick
around the refrigerator
and play around
it, ask questions,
go a little bit deeper
on the technology
if you're interested in that.
And if you need to
get in contact with,
we just got a site
you can go down
to visit as well as
you've got any kind
of potential opportunity
here that you want
to talk a little bit further,
you can reach out to me,
colinmara@google.com.
I'm available to
engage and quarterback
the GCP team and the
Salesforce team together
to help you uncover your
requirements and needs
and guide you
through that journey.
[MUSIC PLAYING]